[Music]
all right welcome back it's time for our
inaugural defending the first segment
where we expose the enemies of the First
Amendment free expression and free
thought all right check this out last
month Rocklin high school in California
placed history teacher
Julian Ben's ell on paid administrative
leave
after she had the gall to question
whether the school would let its
students walk out to do what well to
protest abortion in the same way it did
to promote gun control now one of Ben's
ELL students is putting her question to
the test by organizing a pro-life
walkout set for 10:00 a.m. local time
tomorrow joining us now for more is
Julianne Benz L herself
all right Julianne this is good because
this is like you're a hero of the First
Amendment in my view because the
students in all the organizations who
organized and they did it really well
the March for our lives and the various
walk outs that have occurred over the
last month or so they got huge
participation they got huge media
coverage and most of it was
overwhelmingly positive and glowing what
have you found with your effort at your
school well basically the only large
entity that I know of that has taken up
this pro-life walkout cause is Tony
Perkins of the Family Research Council
I was thinking and to your to your point
there that perhaps there would be other
you know maybe a Clint Eastwood or a
brave movie star from Hollywood because
they had George Clooney funding the gun
protests walkout I was hoping maybe for
you know a few other people to join but
you know what it's all about grassroots
and what we are feeling at the pulse of
the nation right now particularly among
young people is extremely exciting well
I think it's it's interesting that we're
talking about saving lives which we all
want to do we all want to have
sensible regulations that don't run
afoul the Constitution and in this case
the dominant culture does not promote
the cause of life in fact they call the
cause of life anti-abortion rights
advocates that they don't refer to
pro-life on CBS or MSNBC I know because
I used to work at both places they they
say your auntie something but I'm
finding students across the United
States and you see this at the March for
Life every year Julianne are much more
open to the idea of wow this this really
is this is a human being why are we why
are we doing this to the new generation
of Americans we're just stuffing them
out million at a time every year another
million whether it by chemical abortion
or by surgical abortion and yet the
media it's their did they act like this
never this doesn't even this this
viewpoint this pro-life viewpoint
doesn't even exist mm-hmm
correct well and that's precisely why my
very brave student Brendan Gillespie
chose to stage this as a pro-life were
walk out not anti-abortion we are for
all life we are for all students who
have lost their lives by guns on on
school campuses but this is a pro-life
every life matters and you're precisely
right the I forgot her name right now
but the the outgoing president of
Planned Parenthood who said that her
goal was to detail-wise yes that her her
book she want her goal was to deist
stigmatize abortion in the United States
and I'm sorry but that has not taken
place two recent articles that I just
read gave very specific statistics that
the majority of Americans and the
majority of women are pro-life not for
abortion all right Julie Anne thanks so
much I will be following Q what happens
with this brave push to advance life in
a different type of walkout